good morning it's nine o'clock here in
Kiev seven o'clock in the UK on an
extraordinary day the first anniversary
of Russia's war in Ukraine exactly a
year ago President Putin ordered a
full-scale invasion of this country but
a year later Ukraine continues to defy
moscow's seizing back much of the
territory it's lost as allies around the
world vow to keep up their support
this morning we'll look back at a year
of war and we'll be asking how will it
end on our special program this morning
the defense secretary Ben Wallace
Ukrainian politicians and Military
experts plus will be joined by our
correspondents who have been covering
the war on the ground since day one it's
Friday the 24th of February
[Music]
the year of War tributes around the
world as Russia's invasion of Ukraine
enters a second year with no end in
sight to a conflict in which thousands
have been killed
in a calls for a ceasefire we report
from Beijing over fears it could Supply
arms to Moscow as one of former prime
minister gives us this warning
why does China want to be contaminated
by association with with Putin who's
revealed himself to be this gangster and
adventurer
I think Putin as defiant as ever talking
up Russia's nuclear Arsenal as a top
President Biden Envoy tells us it's only
a matter of time before Putin is on
trial for war crimes
new sanctions are expected from G7
leaders meeting virtually later after
yesterday's resounding vote against
Russia in the United Nations
we're on the outskirts of Kirsten now
we're being given a military escort
also reporting from the front line we'll
take a look back at a year of conflict
from our correspondence covering this
war
also this morning Care Home closures we
reveal exclusive data on the industry as
some families are left with
heartbreaking choices
I just couldn't believe it
um
and when I went to see
my husband and told him we did we had a
few tears
police arrest a fourth man in connection
with the attempted murder of an off-duty
policeman shot here in Omar in front of
his son
I don't deserve it Hollywood producer
Harvey Weinstein begs for Mercy as he's
jailed for another 16 years for rape and
sexual assault
foreign
it's exactly one year since Russia
invaded Ukraine firing a series of
missiles towards the capital cave in the
early hours of the 24th of February last
year since then
thousands of people have been killed and
millions of ukrainians have fled their
country in the worst conflict in Europe
since World War II Russia had hoped to
seize Kiev quickly but it's been held
back by Fierce resistance and its own
military blunders in the East and
southfo the fighting rages on
this morning we will be joined by our
correspondents who have been covering
this conflict from the very start our
Moscow correspondent Diana magnet will
bring us the view from Russia our
International Affairs editor Dominic
wagorn is just across the border in
Warsaw but first here's our security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes who is
also in Kiev and Deborah quite a day we
were here a year ago as the Russian
troops we heard had been crossing the
border we heard explosions in the
distance we thought it would be over
uh pretty quickly but we were wrong
we were wrong and I remember standing
with you on
the Anthony on that day 12 months ago
Raid Sirens heard for the were heard for
the first time as missiles crashed down
on the capital and across the country
Keith was turned into a fortress as
troops went out on the streets set up
checkpoints everywhere today it's
remarkable to see cars moving around not
as normal of course it's a country at
War but it's a sign of how far Ukraine
has come over these past 12 months I've
visited the North and the East over the
last month to speak to people who've
been fighting in this conflict from the
beginning
mm-hmm
this was how it started the Russian
onslaught
shocking but also shambolic
these Russian troops invaded from next
door Belarus only to be beaten back
[Music]
12 months on this piece of Ukraine's
broken Border in the north is bristling
with bolstered defenses
new lines of trenches where they watch
and wait
um
no one drops their guard in case Moscow
tries again
[Music]
the Border guards have their own eyes in
the sky Russia's Vladimir Putin hasn't
changed his Focus but for now at least
it's concentrated on the east and south
it's a challenge Ukraine's president
address it is here on our land that we
are protecting the very values that
underpin the life of not only our people
but also the vast majority of European
nations got it to our Warriors glory to
each and every one who is now in combat
thank you to everyone who helps us glory
to Ukraine
this country has been gutted by War
the scars run deepest here in the east
Ern Village
on the first day of the second year of
this war Ukraine remains defiant but the
fighting is only set to intensify
neither side right now has the strength
to achieve a decisive Victory but no
one's in the mood for compromise it
means there'll be many more painful days
months possibly even years
in the capital each flag is planted in
memory of the Fallen
a growing Garden of grief and sacrifice
well we saw president zielinski in that
report from Deborah Haynes there and
we've just heard from the president for
the first time this morning and he says
this he says February the 24th
2022 the date of the Russian invasion he
says was quote the longest day of our
lives and it's also
really proved the longest year of their
lives let's talk to Deborah again now
and Deborah just uh bring us up to date
with where we are in this war what is
the state of the fighting as we speak
well the fighting at the moment is
focused as I said in my report in the
East and in the South Western officials
believe that there are around 300 000
Russian forces in Ukraine that's double
the number of the invading forces that
tried to attack this country from the
North Sea East and the South uh back in
the 24th of February last year but back
moot in the East that City in Donetsk is
the focus of some of the fiercest
fighting and has been for many many
months now Ukrainian troops still
holding the line the Russians had been
hoping to have some kind of new victory
to declare um they like dates the 24th
of February would have been a good date
to have some kind of Battlefield success
Village as well is another key Focus for
the Russian forces but the British
Ministry of Defense in their daily
update they've been doing since the
beginning of the war do believe that
this this focus in the East is maybe
changing and is all of about wearing out
the ukrainians as much as gaining ground
Deborah thank you very much indeed well
China has called for a comprehensive
ceasefire saying it wants to prevent the
Russia Ukraine crisis from getting out
of control but over the last year
Beijing has provided Russia with support
the U.S believes it may be preparing to
ramp up ramp up that support and sell it
weapons Asia correspondent Helen Ann
Smith has this report
[Music]
displays of prowess is something China
is good at the West once hoped this
power could be the broker of Peace but
it but it spent the last year quietly
providing Russia with Finance technology
and diplomatic cover the Americans now
believe it's also preparing to sell arms
position ultimately boils down to a
pretty cynical calculation about what is
best for China it does care about its
International reputation but a
relationship with a strong Russia also
provides Commodities a peaceful northern
border and crucially a like-minded Ally
in an increasingly tense standoff with
the West
and it shifts in that standoff that may
be pushing China closer to Putin
it's right there buddy a row over a spy
balloon just the latest low ebb
in fact China's top Diplomat went to
Moscow this week solidifying what the
two leaders once called a No Limits
friendship
but there is caution too Victor Gower
spent his career amongst the top
echelons of China's leadership and just
listened to how he couches the terms of
that friendship Without Limits doesn't
mean there should be no bottom line
there still should be a bottom line to
your friendship which does not have an
upperceived into it and what should be
the bottom line that is U.N Charter
respecting each other sovereignty and
territorial integrity and whatever
problems or disputes there are you need
to resolve them by peaceful means
reporting of the war is highly sanitized
here America and NATO framed as the
aggressors a useful narrative if China
ever made its own move on Taiwan what it
does next will be watched intently it
could well alter the course of this war
Helena Smith Sky News in Beijing
well yesterday I spoke exclusively to
the former prime minister Boris Johnson
he told me China would be making an
historic mistake if it supplies Russia
with weapons
I think it would be a historic Mistake
by the by the Chinese I was very
concerned to see what Wong Yi was uh was
doing yesterday uh in in Moscow I I
think you know it would be a big mistake
why does China want to be contaminated
by association with with Putin who who's
revealed himself to be this gangster and
and adventurer
and we're just getting word of new
sanctions from uh the UK government on
Russia and those sanctions involve
Banning the export of every item uh
Ukraine has found Russia using on the
battlefield uh to date a foreign
secretary James cleverley announcing
this new package of internationally
coordinated sanctions he says and trade
measure measures including those export
bans on
items Russia has been found using on the
battlefield let's go to Moscow and join
our correspondent Diana magnet and Diana
let's just talk about sanctions how much
impact have they been having and how
worried will the Russians be about these
new sanctions
well I mean I think we've been putting
sanctions on Russia's
military-industrial complex since it uh
it took Crimea in 2014. it's surprising
that there are still sanctions left to
be imposed so to a certain extent I
think that these are always you know the
the the West needs some up its sleeve
and what we're seeing
um particularly in the last few months
because of Russia's use of drones uavs
on the battlefield is an attempt to stop
anything that could contribute to the
manufacturing of drones for Russian
usage but I do think that this is more
symbolic than anything else because
frankly the kinds of measures that
should have been posed on Russia's
military-industrial complex over the
last nine years should have been taking
effect till now
um so that's that's really my take on
sanctions I don't think it's going to
surprise anybody here in Moscow and
sanctions do little other than sort of
make the elites rally around Vladimir
Putin which is a considerable problem in
and of itself we're not expecting any
speeches from Vladimir Putin today Mark
unlike this time a year ago a speech
that changed the world we have heard a
return to the nuclear theme from him
this week yesterday in an address on the
defender of the Fatherland day he said
that some of the Hypersonic nuclear
missiles that Russia has been having in
testing for really a long time now will
be put into service whether that is or
isn't the case it remains to be seen but
it's certainly a signal as is Russia
withdrawing from this new start treaty
um but all in all one year later
Russia's president in a war he thought
would take a matter of weeks shows no
sign of wavering
okay Diana thanks very much indeed let's
go uh from Moscow straight to Warsaw and
speak to Dominic wagorn who is there for
us and Dominic uh talking of sanctions
G7 uh expected to announce new sanctions
today Diana magnet there talking about
pretty much symbolism more than
substance what are your thoughts
yeah the G7 leaders are meeting
virtually today and they are expected to
impose new sanctions and we've just had
this information from the British
foreign office saying that another 92
Russians are going to be sanctioned and
they're going to be sanctioning and
trying to block the export of anything
that the Russians are using on the
battlefield so that includes we're told
aircraft Parts radio equipment
electronic components that can be used
by the Russian military industrial
complex I mean I think as Diana says it
is surprising here and there are any
Russians close to Putin left to sanction
but the British have managed to find
another 92 until now appear to have been
unsanctioned and it is amazing there are
still things that are getting to the
Russians that the West has not found a
way of of blocking so far the problem
really Mark is not sanctioning it's not
imposing sanctions it's actually
enforcing the sanctions because the
Russians have been ingenious as have
their accomplices in this in getting
around sanctions the Russian economy is
expected by the IMF to grow this year
where Britain's might contract and
that's because they've been helped by
China by India by Gulf Nations
particularly to sell their oil on the
black markets the Wall Street journalist
is claiming in reporting overnights that
it's found that China has to to back up
what Helen Ann Smith was saying there in
Beijing China has been sending things
like Jets fighter parts and navigation
equipment Jammy equipment to help the
Russians and that I think corroborates
what the Americans are saying which they
believe the Chinese are on the verge of
sending lethal Aid so they're pretty
much near that already if they're
sending uh parts that are helping the
Russians keep jet fighters in the air to
bomb uh Ukraine so it's not really
imposing sanctions it's actually
enforcing those sanctions and we're
expected to hear more about that as well
from the G7 as it meets virtually later
today
Dominic thank you very much indeed let's
take you straight from Warsaw now to the
southeast of England and uh these are
live pictures of a of a sunrise parade
taking place at a training center for uh
Ukrainian recruits to mark this first
anniversary of the war let's just have a
listen
so uh there we are a moment of
reflection in uh Southeast England for
those Ukrainian recruits who will soon
no doubt be out here fighting for their
country
still to come on the program in just a
few minutes time I'll be talking to the
defense secretary Ben Wallace as calls
Grove for the UK to send fighter jets to
Ukraine I'll also be joined by Ukraine's
youngest MP who took up arms to defend
his country
and I'll speak to the former Russian
Deputy Minister Vladimir milov who is
now an outspoken outspoken critic of the
Kremlin foreign
key for the moment let's go back to Anna
for the day's other news
Mark thanks very much indeed hundreds of
Care Homes closed last year in data seen
exclusively by Sky News as owners
struggled with Rising costs and
increasing numbers of vacancies with
warnings of worst to come
for some families it means they have
just weeks to find somewhere new to live
for their loved ones either Bennett
reports
Jenny Creed's visiting her husband Jim
at his new care home in wrexham but the
move here was not by choice the home
where Jim was living nearby just closed
down and they were given just four weeks
notice to find somewhere new I was just
devastated totally shocked I just
couldn't believe it
um
and when I went to see
my husband and told him we did we had a
few tears he missed the gentleman he sat
next to
um he now prefers to be in his room was
it distressing for him yes it was
distressing for him
and such upheaval is being seen across
the country
247 Care Homes closed their doors last
year twice the number that opened and
for the first time in three years there
was a fall in overall beds
as costs rise staff numbers fall and
without more funding the warnings are
Bleak there's bound to be more closures
because the pressure has become
unbearable for people and people are
hanging on in there that has to be a
reckoning you cannot put a sector like
the social care sector whether the
domiciliary care whether it's Care Homes
you cannot put them under this much
pressure and all this comes at a time
when the country can least afford it
because of the crisis in the NHS to
relieve pressures on hospitals the
government wants to move thousands of
patients into Care Homes but how can
they do that if they keep closing so how
hard are things right now
um there is there's hard as they've ever
been at the moment the doors are still
open at this care home in Bristol but
after 40 years in business they too are
contemplating their future recruitment's
become like a full-time full-time job in
itself but we're suddenly losing them to
like Amazon and the NHS is a big one
supermarkets
because actually suddenly for the same
wages as they could earn hair there's
much much less responsibility and and
stress the stress on the sector though
is impossible to escape
Ivor Bennett Sky News
well in response to our report a
Department of Health and Social care
spokesperson said we're investing up to
7.5 billion pounds in Social care over
the next two years the biggest funding
increase in history which will help
address Workforce pressures and support
person focused Health and Care system
that works closer together
now a fourth person has been arrested by
police in Northern Ireland over the
attempted murder of a senior detective
in front of his own son well our
correspondent Katarina vatazzi is in
Omaha for us this morning so Katarina
what are police saying about the focus
of their investigation here
well shortly after one o'clock this
morning police here in Northern Ireland
confirmed that they had arrested a
Fourth Man a 22 year old from coal
Island here in Northern Ireland it's
about 40 minutes from the scene here in
Omar that fourth arrest made under the
terrorism act we know that yesterday
three men in their 20s and and in that's
right in their 30s and 40s were also
interested in connection with this
shooting on detective Chief Inspector
John Caldwell here on Wednesday night
after an under 15s football training
that he was leading shot by mass gunmen
whilst children were helping him put
footballs into the boot of his car that
fourth arrest made now in connection
with that
Katrina thanks very much indeed
now disgrace Hollywood's producer Harvey
Weinstein has been sentenced to another
16 years in prison for rape and sexual
assault he was found guilty of rape and
two other sexual misconduct charges at a
trial in Los Angeles the 70 year old is
already serving a 23-year sentence after
a separate conviction in New York in
2020.
that's it for me for the moment back to
Mark Austin now in Kiev
thank you very much Anna and I'm pleased
to say I'm joined now by the defense
secretary Ben Wallace thank you very
much for being with us on this day
appreciate your time and if you just
cast your mind back a year and when you
first heard that Russian forces had
crossed the border when you were hearing
that explosions had taken place in this
capital city what was going through your
mind
well I think the first thing was uh you
know I got in touch with my counterpart
to see that he was all right and I think
the first thing is you know is is
everyone all right and uh you know it
was very important for me I'd been to
visit Ukraine a number of times both the
security minister and defense secretary
and you know I know people out there and
I was obviously very concerned uh I was
also sort of filled with a bit of
sadness because despite International
efforts you know both adversary and
friend had done their very best to try
and persuade Russia not to follow this
foolish cause they were just determined
to press on and then lastly I remember
going into the office and saying very
early on you know early in the morning
we have to give Ukraine hope we have to
show the world and we have to show them
in you know in Ukraine and the media we
have to show that Russia is not
infallible that in fact that it can fail
at this and if there is any any Media or
stories that demonstrate like your own
reporting and other reporters you know
of things that show Russia is not having
a success we must to make sure that
people know that far and wide because
it's the hope that has driven these
Brave ukrainians to doing what they're
doing and it's the hope that I think
helped gel the International Community
beyond the initial sort of horror of the
invasion
so let's look ahead then Boris Johnson
told me yesterday that the UK should in
his words break the ice and send Jets to
Ukraine are we going to do that
no we're not going to send our own
typhoon jets in the in the short term to
Ukraine we've been quite clear about
that and you know I I think you know I
the one thing I've learned in in this
conflict is you probably have as well
Mark is you can't rule anything in and
Rule anything out but but I've also
watched uh you know embryonic uh sort of
military aid start with handheld
anti-tank missiles that Britain was the
first in Europe to give before the
conflict growing to now gifting you know
over nearly 200 Western tanks and
helicopters have gone in in huge amounts
of equipment from the International
Community so I've watched it grow that
the key thing here is it's not a sort of
ad hoc plan it's often in response to
the needs on the ground of the
ukrainians but also it's about a realism
you know we we have designed our forces
to fight in a NATO way and that is not
the original design that the ukrainians
inherited when they broke away from the
Soviet Union so so what we have to do is
make sure that when we gift anything
that in some cases we gift the training
and the cape abilities alongside it so
for example gifting a fighter jet Mark
comes with hundreds of people raw you
know Engineers Pilots training
electronic warfare then you know the
more complicated the platforms the
greater the tale and you know the West
is not going to be putting troops into
Ukraine uh in in those scales you know
the idea that you know we would put Thai
food in you'd have to send 200 RAF
people and we're not going to do that
we've said that quite clearly in this
current stage but what we have offered
is that if a country wants to gift a
Russian or a Soviet a model like a
MiG-29 and there are some countries in
in NATO who have them then Britain will
do its very best to either backfill with
our own Jets or indeed provide some form
of air policing to cover that their loss
of vulnerability and capability I think
that's quite important message that's
what the US did in Poland I think with
tanks the polls donated over 200 272s
and they were backfilled by American
Abrahams that that is one of the methods
we've been using over the last year
okay so that you're pretty clear no
typhoons in the near term
um what do you make of Deborah haynes's
reporting yesterday that UK weapons and
ammunition stores are so low that it
risks not being able to support Ukraine
or keep Britain safe
um how short are we of weapons and
ammunition
well first of all very few countries
openly talk about their scale of
stockpiles because to do so would to
leave them vulnerable uh to the enemy
knowing what you have in your bunkers
effectively but look it's not a new uh
observation that this Ukraine war and
the way Russia was fighting has shown
across the West that our stockpiles over
the last three decades have often borne
the brunt of Defense cups or indeed you
know the hollowing act that you've heard
me talk and we have to restock those now
Britain has early on already started
restocking them again what it's also
exposed is that if you think for example
the end laws the anti-tank missiles that
we put in in last January Britain into
Ukraine uh you know we've been placing
orders for these things we've been
buying them in their thousands and once
that orders fulfilled the supply Chain's
gone and done something else and so you
don't you don't just sort of switch a
button you have to reheat that supply
chain and that's been a challenge across
the board but we are fixing it our stock
though are you worried about our stock
I'm not worried about our stock for two
reasons one is we've now started to
place orders to replenish them and where
we haven't placed orders we've started
the work to make sure we have the supply
chain or find alternative sources and
I've already been uh receiving now some
some more end laws those anti-tank
missiles and some low velocity
anti-aircraft missiles into our stocks
and there are more on the way of other
talks so and the second reason I'm not
as worried is you know the the big thing
that Putin respects and is is frightened
off is the NATO alliance that's 30
Nations so remember we are by our
strength and Alliance we are heart of an
alliance of that those 30 countries if
anyone attacks a NATO member we have a
mutual self-defense that's Article Five
off each other and that and that
ultimately gives us our power so we have
a coalition to help support us alongside
the fact we are starting to restore
okay are there any plan just to be clear
are there any plans to ramp up
production of ammunition and weapon
stocks because of the war in Ukraine
absolutely and those plans have been
made public for about six months we've
talked about them and we have either
negotiated with them and you know I
joined a deal a few months ago with uh
Sweden and Finland and Britain to
collectively buy more in-laws we've
started doing that I've visited the
factories and spoken to the leadership
of these countries uh companies sorry
either internationally trying to work
together or indeed individually so these
are not new plans they have been in
place some of the supply chains take
time to reheat and and you know I've
been very honest about that you know I
play with a pretty straight back about
those things to make sure that you know
that you can't just switch a button
because you've got to manage people's
expectations but we're definitely on the
job of that the you know prime minister
gave me an extra 500 million at the
budget to to start restocking the Autumn
statement sorry and so we're on the way
how would you describe your conversation
with the treasury over defense spending
are you confident of getting an increase
in defense spending well I've over the
years I've had many conversations with
the treasury and look I you know the
chance for the Prime Minister indicated
in the Autumn statement something we all
agree with which is that you know
defense needs a greater proportion of
spending or greater amount of spending I
think the statement in Autumn was clear
about that in recognition about the the
growing Global insecurity and of course
I have a spending package that takes me
for another two years at the envelope
and and all I'm really in the position
in this moment is trying to negotiate
around uh you know those lessons we're
seeing from Ukraine and whether there
are any increased risks since our last
budget settlement and you know I'm not
going to carry that out in public but
I'm a I'm a sexual estate sexual states
often have discussions with treasury
whether you're the Department of Health
the Secretary of State or whether you're
the transport sector so of course we
have these conversations
okay Jen just finally
um defense secretary China is publicly
saying that it wants to be a peacemaker
uh between Russia and Ukraine
um but is it your understanding that
China is about to give weapons to Russia
well I've seen the reports in the media
and the United States observations and I
think I think you know it it it can't it
can't help the peace if China
effectively supplies the one nation that
has broken the international law and the
sovereignty of Ukraine and been
inflicting war crimes that will not help
the peace but I'm also confident that
China is pretty clear that it wants this
to stop and you know we'll see the
details of 12. I haven't actually seen
them yet but ultimately Russia China
knows that Russia's Behavior has been
destabilizing you know what's been
interesting over the year is that a
country that is allegedly in Russia's
eyes a friend of it that China has been
abstaining at the UN it hasn't voted
with Russia many times at all and I
think that's quite telling that if the
if you're if your big neighbor doesn't
actually vote actively in support of you
I think it's sending a strong message to
President Putin that this is an unwise
and a Folly that he's the decision that
he's gone down and that he should cease
okay uh Ben Wallace appreciate your time
thanks very much thank you thanks
this goes straight then to Deborah
Haynes who's reporting it was about our
ammunition and weapon stocks so Deborah
pretty clear no typhoons imminently
certainly to Ukraine and he's not
worried about our weapon stocks
well he was very careful wasn't he in
what he said and this is a defense
secretary that has been so
forward-leaning when it comes to
supporting Ukraine he talked about how
when the war started the first thing he
did was call his counterpart here Alexi
reznikov the two of them have a really
close relationship and it's been it's
really appreciated here in Ukraine and
Ben Wallace Boris Johnson at the time
when he was prime minister two names
that are very well known within the
inner circle around president zielinski
so it was interesting to hear that but
yes on Britain's own preparedness he
didn't really want to give too much away
especially on the budget talks and on
this review that I revealed yesterday
that is taking place
um into looking at the size of the UK's
ammunition stockpiles it's a review
that's happening as part of a wider
refresh of defense policy that's going
to be announced the big problem that my
sources tell me is that everybody knows
inside defense that the UK's stock pole
levels need to be expanded significantly
but that requires new funding at scale
and that means that the Prime Minister
and the chancellor need to give defense
much more money when they announce their
budget in March
Deborah thank you very much indeed well
countries right around Europe are
gathering in solidarity with Ukraine to
commemorate one year today since
Russia's illegal invasion of this
country
uh the actress Dame Helen Mirren
addressed crowds at a vigil uh on the
eve of the first anniversary she was
among speakers in Trafalgar Square in
central London celebrating the resolve
of the Ukrainian people and standing up
to uh the ongoing Russian onslaught
what about Paris the Eiffel Tower was
lit up in the colors of the Ukrainian
flag a series of rallies are taking
place
across Europe today to show solidarity
with Ukraine
and the European commission and European
Parliament buildings are both lit up in
blue and gold to Mark the anniversary
and there are of course right here in
Kiev a number of Ceremonies planned
throughout the day and we will bring
those to you of course coming up on Sky
News breakfast we continue our coverage
of the first anniversary of the war in
Ukraine and I'll be speaking to the
country's youngest MP
foreign
welcome back to Kiev as we continue this
special coverage of the first
anniversary of the war in Ukraine and
throughout today there will be special
ceremonies and ceremonial events across
this city in Kiev and other Ukrainian
cities and down below me here there you
see the preparations underway for some
sort of Memorial event because that
there the blue wall you see there is the
Memorial Wall containing the names of
Fallen Ukrainian soldiers and as the
camera pulls back you see some Michael's
Church which is where Joe Biden and
president zielinski had their visit the
other day and then of course we saw
um both presidents laying Reeds at that
wall and uh this uh a major Square in
this uh Capital City preparing for some
sort of event for security reasons we
don't know
specifically what that event is but uh I
think if the camera pulls back a bit
further you can see just in the
background there the carcasses of of
tanks that have been captured
by the ukrainians in uh this war as this
city
commemorates
a year
after the Russian invasion well with me
is uh ukrainia Ukraine's youngest MP I
think I'm right in saying so yaslav but
urash and uh thank you very much for
being with us and as we see you know
these pictures down below us here it is
um well it's a it's a day of
commemoration but of course I mean this
war very much goes on very much so the
reality is that people are dying every
single day and the numbers are just
mind-boggling and every single Ukrainian
you'll meet right now on the streets of
every city around Ukraine will tell your
story of somebody who they've lost
somebody who's fighting somebody who has
fled somebody who lost their livelihoods
somebody had to change their life around
completely the reality is our nation
will know the same of this war in every
single way
I mean you yourself have had great
personal loss
um describe what the past year has been
like and your loss and the effect it's
had on you
fundamental there was the final push
I've got to try and join not just uh
efforts to try and help Ukraine keep
Ukraine the fight but also join the
fight personally after after the dearest
person to Alexandra a journalist
was killed by a Russian Shell near Kiev
after that I joined butcher territorial
defense because I knew they were seeing
fighting and I wanted to fight on that
as badly as possible because the amount
of
hate I fell for all those who killed
this wonderful beautiful young woman who
was as dear to me as can be it was your
girlfriend she was that as well but
through the decade we knew each other
she was everything many times over and
basically it was a decade of different
events in our lives and I can describe
it with that one term simply speaking
Yeah well I'm really sorry for your loss
and as we look more broadly at this war
a year ago when when we were standing
here you were presumably here you you
heard that the Russian troops were
crossing the border you heard distant
explosions did you think then that it
would all be over quite quickly or did
you did you know that your country could
resist by no means it will be quickly
done I knew that discussions in the
years since Russia first invaded Ukraine
in 2014 uh was very clear ukrainians
will not give up their nation and just
give it to Russian to do as Russian
Jesus we will fight in every single way
and even if Russia Russia achieved more
of a success in terms of destroying
unlimited capabilities or destroying our
statehood people would arise and people
would make it uh not a cakewalk by any
measure of imagination I mean all of us
remember that our nation went through so
much worse in 20th century and if our
ancestors survived that and gave us the
chance of Life what I do we have not to
try and do the same thing
now what about weapons and
um fighter jets there is this call by
Ukraine for fighter jets how important
is that to you fundamental as we are
preparing to liberate other parts of
Ukraine we need to propel offensive in a
way that is successful efficient and
quick and for that we need to apply
combined Arts theory that is we need
heavy elements and we need air power and
basically for that reason we are asking
for instance of war from the Arsenal
democracy that the West certainly is
I've just been speaking to our defense
secretary the UK defense secretary who
has effectively ruled out sending
typhoon Jets anytime soon what would
your message be to him well when I see
image of zelensky and the prime minister
of the UK wearing
air pilot helmets and I see that as a
message that certainly some steps will
be taken this direction and as far as
jets are concerned we have seen many
other countries in the native space
making the same points so as in all
cases with the weapons and means for
Ukraine to wage this War uh and to try
and defend itself the point is that
first it's impossible then it's hard
then it's difficult and then it's doable
and it's done and the sooner we will
take that step the final step the better
I think it's fair to say and you will
probably agree that Ukraine's survival
depends on West's continued Western
support with Weaponry that you've just
been
discussing do you think and that will
require Western Unity do you think that
the West NATO countries will remain
United even if this war carries on for
one two maybe three years the reality as
we are seeing not just words we are
seeing commitments of various various
forms political legal uh and
treaty-bound commitments to the fact
that the this war is something that is
ultimately an affront to every every
idea of the national World Order in this
in any sense so the West is committed to
this that's why Joe Biden was here a few
days ago to Showcase that the leader of
the Free World is here to Showcase that
this commitment is until we get Russians
out okay
thank you very much as we await for this
uh ceremony going on behind us I
appreciate your time my pleasure is
awesome thank you very much indeed
well throughout the past year the city
of Hakeem has come under almost constant
bombardment worst hit the area of
saltivka just 20 miles from the Russian
border we've been back there to meet the
few remaining people enduring
extraordinary hardship there and who
fear that it could soon happen all over
again
[Applause]
saltivica remains a broken place
broken buildings broken infrastructure
and in the grip of this cruel winter
broken people
Anatoly limerenko has a face worn by War
he is 61 years old and he is the only
person still living in his badly damaged
nine-story block of flats
[Music]
it is a hard climb to the seventh floor
place he still calls home
it is scarcely that so
it's cold it's really cold
he has gas to cook and soup to keep him
going but there is no heating no hot
water and the toilet doesn't work
because the system water froze and it
cracked but despite it all he stays I
have nowhere else to go he says
it's scary to be on your own but when
there is no shelling it's bearable it
wasn't that sweet three kilometers stand
Russian and the bump here
during the days during the night
just after War Began we met Raman in
saltivka ferrying supplies to the
desperate here between bombardment he is
still doing it
these women show us the flats destroyed
by Russian fire
where missiles went through the floor
and where the lives of neighbors came to
an end
and living next door to the burnt out
shell of an apartment we found 71 year
old nelia tuba who is often thought
about leaving
but instead stays with her bed-ridden
husband Petro
they do at least have Heating in this
block
but her fear is that the Russians will
try again to take the city
this place represents Putin's War not
against the Ukrainian military but
against the Ukrainian people 40
000 people lived here now it is barely a
handful and for them the conditions are
desperate
[Music]
Anatoly sitting watching jazz on a
television with barely a signal
this is what war has done to soltifka to
its few remaining people to the spirit
of what they say used to be a happy
place
[Music]
by the former Russian Deputy energy
Minister now staunch critic of the
Kremlin of Vladimir milov thank you very
much for being with us I just wonder
first of all are you surprised how badly
Russia has been doing in this war
no actually not so good morning and uh
this is the reason why I did not believe
that the invasion would take place uh
because uh we many of my colleagues we
were actually aware uh of the poor
status of the Russian army and uh we
also communicated a lot with ukrainians
who understood that they would fiercely
resist this Invasion so all this you
know roll over in three days like many
had predicted uh this was uh just an
unbelievable scenario to us so this is
why we thought that Putin is better
informed to take this crazy step and uh
actually it was a big surprise that he
finally did
why do you think Vladimir Putin
miscalculated so badly
well I think he only counted on scenario
a which was a snap operation uh
reminiscent of the invasion of
Czechoslovakia in 1968 when they wanted
to take the airport in hastomel right
near Kiev something 10 miles away from
Kiev they wanted to bring in a lot of
elite troops and heavy Weaponry to take
the government quarter and decapitate I
think it's now pretty clear that the
hastoma airport was the key direction of
attack after they failed to capture the
airport we saw that there's clearly no
plan B and it was visible that the
masses of troops that they've been
sending out to the front lines were not
really ready for like a long and heavy
offensive operations they really
believed in that decapitation scenario
and didn't have much in their pocket to
substitute it when it failed
uh looking ahead do you think Ukraine
can defeat Russia can defeat Putin
oh yeah definitely yes also the question
is how do you find defeat in terms of
returning all these illegally occupied
Ukrainian territories I think definitely
yes in the coming months and years
Ukrainian are able of doing this big
question is what happens next because if
Putin is not removed from power in
Russia if we continue with this
aggressive imperialistic regime it will
rethink regroup replenish and then
strike back probably in a few years
which is why a regime change in Russia
remains a crucial issue over Global
Security
so that's interesting you think if um
Russian forces are pushed out that could
be the end for Putin do you
this is questionable because
um in over 20 years in power Putin has
destroyed anything in Russia we have no
Elite in the classical Western political
sense we just have a bunch of
incapacitated very frightened people we
don't have any political mechanisms uh
to turn the popular discontent into
political change and people are very
scared like nearly every day some new
article of the criminal code is
introduced with heavy prison terms and
penalties for descent so there's a
dangerous vacuum it's really hard to
predict how political changes can occur
after Putin's defeat but I sincerely
hope that that will be the way forward
and his authority and his reputation
inside Russia will not be able to
withstand such a blow
okay uh Vladimir milov thank you very
much indeed
thank you my pleasure
now the front man of the Ukrainian Group
which won last year's Eurovision song
contest hopes his country will be able
to host the show next year uh the folk
rap group uh Kayla shulkester took the
Eurovision top spot last year in Turin
which would traditionally mean they host
the event the following year but due
to the war here of course the UK is
hosting the 2023 contest uh on their
behalf
and let's just have a look uh at that
Eurovision
um sound
[Music]
and Deborah Haynes is with me here in
Kiev Deborah as we come to the top of
the hour just some thoughts on this uh
on this day of commemoration
[Music]
well just that music that you played
it's it's
of ukrainians it's very much symbolic of
the war you hear it being played by
soldiers you hear it um at petrol
stations around this country this
country's been United in terms of its
sovereignty its identity in a way that
um few could have imagined a year ago 12
months ago when Russia launched its
Invasion most analysts were saying they
expected Kiev to fall within days
Ukraine so it showed itself to be
resilient Russia showed itself to be
unable to do that and the war continues
and Deborah I mean we heard from Ben
Wallace earlier
um no typhoon Jets and but he did talk
also about ammunition stocks and he's
confident he has those so we'll talk
about that uh in the next hour let's
just have a look below us at the
preparations that are going on for the
commemoration here in Kiev the Memorial
Wall uh outside St Michael's Church
something clearly due to be going on
here in the next few moments ceremonies
across Ukraine on this day and we'll
bring you more from here
at the top of the hour
[Music]